what solve leak code 167 to some to so
we're given an input array that's
already sorted in ascending order and we
want to find two numbers that sum up to
some target that we're also given so in
this case the target is nine the two
numbers that sum up to nine in this
array are two and seven and we want to
return the indices of these two values
but the catch here is that the indexes
are one based they're not zero based so
the first element has index 1 the second
element has index 2
I don't know why exactly they did that
in this problem it's kind of weird but
they did for some reason we're also
guaranteed that there's exactly one
solution and we can't use the same
number twice so in this example that
they gave us the two numbers the two
first numbers sum up to the target so
that's not really a good example so I'm
gonna look at my example over here that
I drew so the first idea that might come
to your mind is just look at every
single combination of two numbers so
let's say we're starting at the first
number one let's look at every number
combined with one and see if it can sum
up to the target nine so first we check
1 plus 3 that is 4 so it's not 9 then we
check 1 plus 4 that's 5 then we check 1
plus 5 that's 6 1 plus 7 is 8 and 1 plus
10 is 11 so now we've gotten to the
point where at 1 plus 10 but the
interesting thing about this is this is
the first combination that's greater
than our target 9 so do we have to keep
looking at the next element since we
know the array is already sorted there's
no number that's gonna come after 10
that's gonna be added to 1 that could
possibly some to the target 9 so since 1
plus 10 is already greater than the
target we don't have to look at the
remainder of the array because there's
no number that could possibly come after
10 added to 1 that would ever be the
target every number is gonna be greater
than the target so we don't have to
consider 11 anymore
so we basically remove it from
consideration from our array so we
didn't find the two numbers that sum to
the target so now let's try if there's
any combination with 3 that could
possibly some 2
so we start at 4 so 3 plus 4 is 7 3 plus
5 is 8 3 plus 7 is 10 so this is the
first combination 3 plus 7 which is 10
is greater than the target 9 so we don't
have to look at any number that comes
after 7 because we know that it will
never equal the target so we can
basically say well 10 is removed from
consideration we don't even have to look
at it so we couldn't find a combination
with 3 that could sum to the target 9 so
now let's check the next number for the
first number after 4 is 5 in this case 4
plus 5 is exactly our target 9 so we
found the solution of course since we
found the solution we don't have to
consider any element that comes after it
so in this case 7 is removed from
consideration and we can return our
solution and remember that these indices
are based on 1 so the first index is 1
the second index is 2 3 & 4 so the
indices that we're going to be returning
are 3 & 4 so since this is a brute force
solution and we're having to iterate
through the entire array which is length
N and we're going to potentially do that
in the worst case n times for each
number in the array so then that means
our worst case time complexity is Big O
of N squared so it's not very efficient
but can we use the fact that this array
is sorted to our advantage let's look at
the picture we just drew first we
eliminated 11 from consideration in the
array then we eliminated 10 then we
eliminated 7 so we're basically
eliminating elements from the end of the
array in reverse order can we use this
to our advantage this is basically the
intuition remember this array is sorted
we can use that to our advantage so
let's try the exact same problem with a
slightly different algorithm using what
we just learned
our target is still 9 since we're
eliminating elements from the end of the
array we can use two pointers one
pointer is going to be at the beginning
or a left pointer one pointer is going
to be at the end or
the right pointer so we currently have a
one and an eleven let's add these
together one plus 11 is equal to 12 so
that's greater than our target of nine
remember so since this target is too big
we need to decrease it we have a choice
of which pointer to shift if we shift
our left pointer here to three we're
going to be increasing the sum we don't
want to do that since the sum is already
too big so instead let's take our right
pointer and shift it to the left now
we've decreased the total sum so let's
recompute it one plus seven now it's
eight this is too small we went a little
- we decreased our sum too much so now
we need to increase it so since the
array is sorted we can take our left
pointer and shift it to the right to
increase our total sum now we've
increased our sum so it's now three plus
seven but we went too far again right
now it's too big again it's bigger than
nine so what do we have to do this time
well we want to decrease our sum so
we're going to take the right pointer
and shift it left so now we decreased
our sum let's recompute it three plus
five but that's eight so again we got to
a it's too small again but we're
guaranteed a solution so we're gonna
keep looking
since our sum is too small we're gonna
increase it by taking our left pointer
and shifting it right now we can't
really shift our pointers anymore so we
better be at the right solution let's
check four plus five that's exactly nine
so we got our target and so we want to
return the indices of these which are
going to be three and four right in this
case we don't have to iterate through
the entire array more than once and
these left and right pointers are never
going to cross each other we don't need
extra memory either so our time
complexity in the worst case is a Big O
of n we found a linear algorithm using
two pointers to solve this problem we
didn't even need extra
now we're ready to code up the solution
so we remember we have two pointers left
and right the left pointer is going to
be at the beginning of the array so
index 0 the right pointer is going to be
at the last index length of numbers
minus 1 and we need a loop to iterate
through our array the condition in this
case is left is less than right but it
doesn't really matter because we're
guaranteed a solution so we're going to
return a solution no matter what so like
we just did in the example let's compute
the current sum and we remember if our
current sum is too big so if it's
greater than the target we can decrease
our sum by taking our right pointer and
shifting it to the left on the other
hand if the current sum is too small we
want to increase our sum by taking the
left pointer and shifting it to the
right the last case is that our current
sum is exactly equal to the target in
that case we want to return the indices
left and right but remember they're
based on 1 so we're going to add 1 to
each of them we can put our return out
here but it's not needed because we're
guaranteed a solutions where a loop will
return the solution and it works
perfectly a linear time algorithm with
no extra space make sure to like if this
was helpful and subscribe if you want
more